tenemos aquí tres gráficas la gráfica de
fx que es este de aquí sube baja sube la
gráfica de eje x que es esta de aquí
baja y sube y la gráfica de hdx que es
esté aquí va por aquí y va por acá ok y
yo lo que quiero o más bien lo que
necesito en este vídeo es asociar cada
una de las gráficas de estas funciones
con estas funciones que tengo aquí y
para eso voy a utilizar lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado acerca del
comportamiento en los extremos y está
padrísimo porque ahora si te vas a dar
cuenta de para que nos puede servir
saber el comportamiento de los extremos
de una función o de un polinomio o bueno
en este caso son funciones polinómicas
así que vamos a hacerlo en el primer
caso tengo y es igual a un medio de x
cuadrada menos 9 medios ok ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que esta
función de aquí es una parábola porque
es una función cuadrática y además
tenemos al lado del término más grande
al lado a un valor positivo es decir un
medio por lo tanto podemos decir que
esta es una parábola que abre hacia
arriba que se ve más o menos así se debe
de ver más o menos así ok
una parábola que abre hacia arriba y
creo que con esto ya podemos buscarla la
única parábola de estas tres que abre
hacia arriba es gd x de x entonces ahora
sí sin miedo a equivocarnos podemos
decir que gdx kg de x es exactamente lo
mismo que un medio de x cuadrada menos 9
medios y cómo puedo saber eso bueno
porque esta expresión de aquí es una
parábola que abre hacia arriba y aquí
tengo solamente una parábola que abre
hacia arriba
x y además si no estamos completamente
seguros podemos fijarnos en qué es lo
que pasa con el término libre aquí
tenemos menos nueve medios que es lo
mismo que menos 4.5 y si x va de 0 esto
de aquí sería 0 y solamente nos
quedaríamos con 9 menos 9 medios lo cual
es menos 4.5 que es la intersección con
el eje layes y está de lujo es esta de
aquí aquí tengo una intersección de
menos cuatro quintos y ahora sí podemos
estar completamente seguros y sentirnos
cómodamente porque gdx tiene esta
gráfica que tenemos aquí ahora vamos a
fijarnos en las otras dos y aquí tengo
déjenme cambiar de color y voy a
trabajar con un color neutro se me
ocurre este de aquí ahora voy a tomarme
esta expresión que tengo aquí esta
expresión que tengo aquí que por cierto
qué te parece si analizamos que
coeficiente y qué grado tendría el valor
más grande de este polígono que tengo
aquí ahora date cuenta que esta función
no podemos ver de la siguiente manera
esto es lo mismo que y es igual y aquí
me quedaría menos 1
que multiplica a su vez a equis y lo más
grande que podemos tener es que esta x
multiplica a su vez a x cuadrado es
decir que lo más grande que podamos ver
en esta función es un décimo que
multiplica a x ubica x por equis
cuadradas x cúbica y este es el valor de
x más grande que puede tomar la función
y después pues va a pasar algo con la
función no es necesario poner todo lo
demás aquí le vamos a sumar o restar
algunos términos y vamos a ponerles
suman vamos a sumar algunos términos más
ok todos estos hasta llegar al término
final y cuál es el término final o el
término libre de este polinomio que
tengo aquí bueno pues es lo que no tenga
que ver con equis y eso lo podemos
generar multiplicando menos 9 por 3 por
menos un décimo menos 11º por 3 por 9 es
lo mismo que más que más porque menos
por menos es más 9 por 36 27 27 entre 10
es 2.7
27 decimos como lo que has ver pero
ahora si yo tengo este polinomio de aquí
y utilizo el conocimiento que vimos la
vez pasada te vas a dar cuenta que este
es un polinomio público y los polinomios
cúbicos se comportan de la siguiente
manera recuerda si a era mayor que 0 y
ya es el valor que está al lado de x
cúbica entonces tenemos un polinomio que
habría más o menos así bajaba subía algo
pasaba y después llegaba hasta este
punto esto en el caso de que fuera mayor
que 0 se veía más o menos así la gráfica
de una función cúbica cuando el
coeficiente que estaba al lado de la x
cúbica era positivo pero en este caso
tenemos un coeficiente negativo por lo
tanto es menor que cero es menos
undécimo y entonces habíamos dicho que
se veía más o menos así la gráfica de la
función cúbica y bueno voy a poner
solamente el comportamiento de los
extremos más o menos tendré que pasar
algo así algo más o menos así pero lo
que quiero que veas es que si x tuvo un
valor muy pero muy pero muy negativo x
cómica tendrá un valor muy negativo y
por algo me quedaría algo positivo se va
a ver más o menos así y después si x
toma un valor positivo entonces x cúbica
toma un valor positivo y positivo por
algo negativo me va a dar algo negativo
por eso se va a ver más o menos así
aunque esto se ve medio raro pero se
vería más o menos así y si te das cuenta
la única gráfica que se ve más o menos
así es hd x hdx baja pega sube y baja
entonces hdx podemos decir que es esta
función de aquí ya sin miedo a
equivocarnos podemos decir que gracias
al comportamiento final y el
comportamiento inicial este de aquí es
hd x y todo esto porque nos dimos cuenta
de que el término el coeficiente que
estaba al lado de la equis pública el
coeficiente era negativo ahora si no
estás completamente seguro podemos
analizar qué es lo que pasa con el
término libre es decir cuando esté aquí
te das cuenta es 2.7 así que cuando x es
cero todo esto se haría cero todo esto
que está aquí en medio sería cero porque
tiene que ver con - este que es el
término libre entonces quiere decir que
cuando x es cero interceptamos al eje de
las 10 en el valor de 2.7 y si te das
cuenta hdx intersecta al eje de las 10
en el valor de 2.7 que es justo este de
aquí así que ahora si estamos
completamente seguros de que esto es lo
que pasa muy bien así que ya aparece que
esta de aquí la última y déjame agarrar
otro color un poco neutro am se me
ocurre este de aquí no no es si lo
ocupamos se me ocurre tomar mejor este
de aquí ahora si me fijo en esta
expresión de aquí podremos concluir que
es ftx pero vamos a hacerlo con calma
para esto déjame quitar este pedazo que
tengo aquí lo voy a quitar no me sirve
por ahorita y me voy a fijar en esta
expresión que tengo de aquí abajo ahora
esta expresión que tengo aquí abajo si
te das cuenta la podemos ver de la
siguiente manera como y es igual y qué
te parece si buscamos el coeficiente y
de qué grado es este polinomio que tengo
aquí abajo bueno si te das cuenta el
grado más grande lo podemos obtener
multiplicando a x 4 por equis cuadrado
sin embargo no te olvides de este
undécimo se va a ver como un décimo que
multiplica a x 4x cuadrada por equis
cuadrada me da x 4a y esto le vamos a
sumar algunos otros términos varios
varios más hasta llegar al último
término al término libre que sale de
multiplicar 9 por 9 por 1 entre 10 lo
cual es 91 81 sobre 10 8.1
8.1 ok y bueno vamos a ver si realmente
es fx esta función que tengo aquí y para
eso date cuenta que tenemos un
coeficiente al lado de la x 4a positivo
entonces ya podemos ver más o menos cómo
se ve la gráfica de esta función de esta
función de grado 4 utilizando el
comportamiento en los extremos si te das
cuenta si x tuvo un valor muy pero muy
pero muy negativo entonces aquí x 4a me
daría algo positivo cuando elevó algo el
negativo a la cuarta potencia me da algo
positivo y después x algo positivo me da
algo positivo por lo tanto se tendría
que ver algo así
y después si x es algo muy pero muy pero
muy positivo a la cuarta sigue siendo
positivo y x un décimo sigue siendo
positivo entonces tiene que salir algo
así y aquí en medio quien sabe que pase
bueno más o menos sabemos que pasará
algo así sube baja algo como un camello
pero lo importante lo que quiero que
veas es que el comportamiento final e
inicial de esta función cuadrática que
tengo aquí es que en un inicio toma
valores positivos y al final también
toma valores positivos muy parecido al
comportamiento de una parábola pero no
es una parábola porque quien medió pasa
algo raro y si te das cuenta fx fx
cumple justo eso cuando x es muy
negativa toma valores positivos después
bajas se vuelve cada vez menos positiva
después de aquí cambia cambia y después
cuando x es muy positiva este esta
gráfica toma valores positivos justo
como ya habíamos dibujado aquí abajo y
todo esto gracias al comportamiento de
los extremos entonces podemos decir sin
miedo este de aquí es f de equis y bueno
si tú tuvieras todavía un poco
desconfianza nos podemos fijar en el
término libre que es donde interceptamos
al eje de las 10 y 8.1 es justo este de
aquí que es la función fx por lo tanto
estamos bien ya encontramos las tres
gráficas fijándonos en el comportamiento
de los extremos y además corroborando lo
con este término libre